oh hey
happy friday america
yep i can already smell the weekend
it's like the smell of wet fur in front
of a warm fire
but enough about my back
today let's honor the brave board of
supervisors of los angeles county did
they finally solve their rampant
homeless and drug addiction problem
course not did they clean up skid row
fat chance did they reverse the rise in
murder and gang violence not on your
life are they at least protecting
celebrities from award show slappings
no they did something more amazing they
barred official travel to florida
because the state's parental rights bill
or what the idiots call the don't say
gay law you know the law that bans
in-depth instruction of sex and gender
to kids third grade and under
it's the law that if you're against it
could explain why you hide a bag of
lollipops under your trench coat so what
was florida's response to hearing l.a
county staffers won't be coming
[Applause]
yeah talk about inconsolable the la
board claims the law harms trans kids
but they have less evidence of that than
we have that brian stelter has abs
but i say hooray i am so happy there are
people who want to teach toddlers about
sex because you don't want a
four-year-old boy making an ass of
himself when he makes his move on
brittany in the sandbox
normally people would find this age
inappropriate
but no says the la board let's get these
brats while they still have that soft
spot on their heads
eight-year-olds four-year-olds
one-year-old what's the difference maybe
a couple of baby teeth
that's the problem with toddlers they
can barely talk about radical feminism
let alone gender identity
so why not show them war crime footage
while we're at it get them ready
now we wish this florida law didn't have
to exist but it does
it's like the warning on a dry cleaning
bag telling you not to place it over
your head that means someone has already
done it
it's also the death of age
inappropriateness no responsible adult
lets a child drive a car or vote or get
a tattoo so why would we force kids to
talk about sex and gender when they
should be thinking about nap time and
recess
of course the travel ban is pointless
virtue signaling and really it punishes
the l.a county workers because where
would they rather be in the summer
here in la the home of infamous skid row
or here in florida the home to miles of
beautiful beaches
or would you rather be here a place
where crime and violence flourishes
or be here a place defined by fun in the
sun
and who would you prefer to hang out
with these empty-headed celebrities
or this
yeah
how is that not gay
you can't spell manatee
without man
fact is l.a county is way more anti-gay
because they're anti-people in general
and florida is more pro-gay than l.a
because they're pro-freedom and pro-fun
rather than protect gays or straights
from hate crime or any crime they exact
their justice against a state florida
that's minding its own damn business and
as richard grinnell the first openly gay
cabinet member of us history points out
there is no ban on travel to the 69
countries that criminalize homosexuality
so sure buy a time share in tehran
but whatever you do stay the hell out of
key west
but these l.a county creeps claim that
this florida bill is about stifling safe
exploration of ideas you know like
they're discussing bezos next space
flight or the future of electric cars
no it's about sex and no sane person
wants an adult initiating that
with your five-year-old at best it's
gross and at worst it's predatory the
board also banned travel to texas after
that state categorized some transgender
medical procedures for minors as child
abuse they claim that ban impedes
children from discovering who they are
and feel secure in their sense of self
again it's word perversion disguised as
enlightenment no child should undergo
unnecessary medical procedures unless
it's hair plugs for babies with huge
bald heads
scare me but these idiots think the cure
for perhaps a temporary gender confusion
is surgery
but you do that and you may just get rid
of gay and lesbian adults and replace
them with surgically altered
heterosexuality how is that not
homophobic
besides all kids go through phases
for one year i was convinced i was lassy
god i was such a [ __ ]
but florida must count itself lucky that
these l.a loons aren't coming imagine
what they're like miserable cretans who
look terrible in athletic wear
delivering messages that are meant to
show they care when really they just
expose themselves as destructive creeps
yeah they expose themselves not
surprising
let's welcome
she's my favorite mcdonald besides old
host of the evening edit on fox
business mcdonough
and he's only here because he looks
great in swim trunks
president of the douglas society
it was on instagram rob
open game
rob smith
yes yeah
you know every weekend is like easter
with cat in that when she rises again on
monday morning we considered it a
miracle fox news contributor cat tim
and finally our origin story is like
jack and the beanstalk he's a giant and
i stalked him
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion tyra's
rob i'm going to go to you first because
you are from florida
what are your thoughts on the travel ban
um well first of all i'd like to say uh
i live in florida so i moved to florida
during the pandemic i am a practicing
homosexual right so i say this because
it is relevant to this conversation i
think that the ban is complete nonsense
it's bs it's virtue signaling it's woke
signaling it is not making the lies of
gays and lesbians in california any
better to do this political posturing
and i have to say that all of this stuff
this really isn't about gays and
lesbians this is about the gender cult
this is about the gender identity cult
that's telling um these kindergartners
pre-k first and second graders that
there are 100 genders they're teaching
them the pride flags all of that stuff
and i say as somebody that you know was
a gay teenager and and you know became a
gay adult that
in this day and age if there are kids
that are gender non-conforming in any
way maybe they're tomboyish girls or
their you know feminine boys now they
want to tell them that they're trans get
them on all of this what they're calling
life-affirming health care um and and
it's really really bad for these kids
yeah it's it it's kind of strange it's
like talk about like the most intrusive
solution for something that naturally
can take care of itself the person just
becomes gay by the way as a practicing
homosexual how long before you got good
at it
i don't know i'll give you a list of my
partners okay
liz liz list do you think this is a
priority that the la county
board should be focusing on when they
have crime homelessness drug addiction
right no i i mean it's some i feel like
it's a public menace yeah for what
they're you know
if you need an affirmation of a five
from a five-year-old
gay or straight then you're a weirdo and
it's a pub you're a public menace i it's
by the way what i think in florida you
learn about sex education by the sixth
grade or seventh grade so what do you
need it for back then by the way sheila
kuhl who's leading the charge on this is
the one who was saying no you can't eat
out at restaurants right and she was the
one who broke her own rule
eating out at a restaurant without a
mask and she's the one who's pushing for
defunding the police i'm thinking that
we're probably going to see her in a
groucho marx disguise at florida's
disney world like next week like coming
to florida anyway right exactly it's not
going to stop no it's not going to stop
them right right they're doing it to the
the people that work for them tyrus but
not for them
if they got if they got an airbnb in key
west they're going
yeah again when you break down the
dynamic of these bored these people on
these boards i don't think anyone's
boo-hooing that they're not coming you
just have to you just have to shake your
head like
my kids for example
my son is very sensitive
he doesn't he's not aggressive and i
love him to death and i don't care which
way he goes
but he's gonna find that on his own and
one day we'll figure it out as a family
my daughter when she's with me she's a
tomboy she chases snakes and cusses like
a sailor and does all the things that we
like to do but when she's with her mom
she wears her dresses and makeups and
behaves like a normal
human being yeah
normally
if someone just decided to tell me
because when they see her with me
opposed to when they see with her mom
that oh well she needs to work on
transitioning to be a little boy
i'd be like shut up yeah
[Laughter]
a lot of my in wrestling wrestling
everybody's gay sometimes
so wrestling is very gay yeah super gay
and
some of my friends though they didn't
figure out that they were gay until
their 30s
when they had their awakening or their
understanding or whatever
but no one at one point could you
imagine that someone telling them how
they needed to be during their journey
to become
who they are and i think we need to
think about that like sometimes the
answers aren't always as a child it's
sometimes not even as a teenager
there's i have a friend who was married
with three kids and happy and then woke
up one morning and was like
i'm gay yeah and i don't know what i've
been doing for the last 20 years so
but we need to allow that yeah and not
people experts on nothing telling you
what to do is is tragic and terrible
it's weird it's a very weird thing cat
uh where would you like to be banned
from going
relief you know if somebody says you
can't come to
any more
i don't know i'm trying to think
comic-con oh yeah i also have star wars
comic-con is the worst comic-con is
actually it never gets easier to see a
grown adult man in a batman costume
it never
gets easier and also it's not like these
are attractive people they're never
there's not an attractive person at
comic-con no because then they would be
elsewhere
and speaking of attractive i mean look
there's no red-blooded gay man that's
going to resist travel to texas from in
florida from l.a like you know guys in
texas and florida are way hotter than
guys in california i just have to put
that up you know you're right i think
texas and florida is like really happy
we have enough californians here that's
right that's true oh i'd like to be
banned from all baby showers oh yes oh
really i never like i never know what to
say like what do i have to offer in that
situation exactly exactly like to be
banned from all car conversations oh
really yeah i hate when people start
talking when you're driving oh that's an
interesting thing yeah i thought you
meant talking about cars but
or if anytime lacrosse is on the tv i
die so i can't be around it
actually i was just diagnosed with that
interesting yeah well i got i would like
to be banned i would like to be banned
from washington d.c i just got in i'm
with you i'm yeah i'm good um i don't
know if you guys have got your
invitation to the correspondence dinner
yeah did you get it yeah are you i
turned it i said no immediately i don't
know i kind of like i gotta go fire you
are gonna go we should go as a group
yeah yeah you have to go as a group you
have to make a conservative sort of
presence felt and then get banned
together i just want to look really
pretty okay you guys are going to eat it
you're going to hate it i'm telling you
i'm bringing a floating dumpster fire
they're yelling i love that i can
pretend to be you and i can just go in
your place
you're not as good-looking but we'll
we're gonna have to slouch you have to
slouch just a coach all right we gotta
move up next a biden nominee is asked to
repeat what she meant by an old mean
tweet hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else